cameras can y'all get that like get
snoops like feet comfortably
they get mine like the difference in
comfort uh between kevin and snoop he
must be swinging his feet like the
goddamn wizard of oz have you ever been
to the olympics event i've never been to
the olympics i've never been so i'm so
honored to be here live in tokyo at the
olympics this year uh i've never been to
the limited edition how about you let me
ask you [ __ ] you just asked
somebody that's that's how fast i am i
see you too quick
you know i'd say the beginning of this
is actually man it's nothing like the
beginning of the oscars both big events
but uh not not the same at all yeah have
you been to the oscars you know god did
when i've been asked you know what the
hell happened to me it's a selfish
question that's a selfish question is
that a tokyo sign behind us or a paris
uh eiffel tower what is that i thought
we was looking in new york the whole
time i believe she is uh what is that
that's a alaska right where she's from
again alaska okay so is she alaskan or
is she american
[Music]
oh you [ __ ] me up on that one smith i
don't know
i don't know
i don't know
i'm an islam boy i put my vest on yeah
like a while grandma and try to make it
to the top i seen it with a gang gang
slang yo
they got to use that word
i'm speechless
two goofballs in the pool you know why
i'm not speechless why
because of my island
[Laughter]
what is happening i don't know and ain't
trying to understand it damn it what's
understood don't need to be explained
i don't want to understand it it doesn't
need to be explained what
how i became my island boy
knock it off man you know i've been up
all night i ain't get to bed at like
four in the morning four in the morning
yeah what's your old ass doing up to
four in the morning would you he was all
partying no i was studying our own
olympic research binder you study what
the olympic research binder getting my
research together who gave you a binder
you ain't got one no i want no binder
anybody give me no binder
why you got a binder
so you got three nobody gave me a binder
great i need some tissue i've been
crying my my eyes hold on we got some
pick up questions we're gonna do god
damn my eyes is water you want me to be
crying on tv
bring me some tissue card real quick
like this [ __ ] called continuity ain't
that what y'all worried y'all like using
are we rolling yeah we on there yeah
first of all y'all gotta tell me when we
back we're back don't don't bring us out
of it and not have me know
listen at the end of the day respect me
you got to talk to him like that i like
that that was gangster i mean i was
actually watching now a [ __ ]
need to know how i wrote that [ __ ] right
straight up you know you get tougher
when you're with tougher people
something about being next to you makes
me feel good
i'll kick a [ __ ] in the back see
what i'm saying
i wouldn't i would never do it but it
makes me i got you though
okay
i'm gonna share my gold medal with you
what in the it should only be one winner
i mean look i get the the camaraderie i
get the idea of it but ultimately the
olympics are the olympics for a reason
you want one person to win the gold one
to win the silver one to win the bronze
that's the beauty of being able to say
you the best i don't want to share my
best moment with you but hold on kev the
podium ain't big enough for both of us
who the [ __ ] the [ __ ] want to double
share a podium
come on bro move over scoot your ass
over man
let me get some bruh i'm trying let me
be on tv let me get some bro let me get
we got a whole look you got [ __ ] we over
here doing this on one side look you
hold a piece and i hold a piece
and finally anastasia zalatic
is that it zalo titch
it's a low teacher okay it's a low titch
the low
here we go how about i give it to you
seven different ways and y'all take the
right one ask her what it is anastasia
zalo titch you did yeah close to zella
[ __ ] you understand me became the first
u.s woman to win a gold medal and tie
right now oh i'm looking at the wrong
camera though
well you nailed that name
you nailed the [ __ ] out of that name in
his gold medal wrestling match against
georgie and gino pete radish's valley
[Laughter]
i mean
how do you dude do you understand how
much does that ball weigh 17 pounds how
the [ __ ] do you know all this
i'm so sick of your [ __ ] man
got all the goddamn answers he know
everything i'm a numbers guy my fault 17
17 pounds what
who told you that is there somebody in
your hair
feeding you this [ __ ] you know every
damn thing pissing me off
okay
how do i i would love to know the rules
of how that's gonna break down and if
it's teams is it teams again well don't
pass it over here brother come here come
on
i'll make my heart beat brother come on
now ah well where did they go ah
i want to eat it now come on do they
start off with you know smaller five
smaller yeah yeah okay they got to just
like the high jump you know high jump
start off two feet yeah just getting the
technique together getting them what'd
you
yeah what happened to you
[Laughter]
you just had a stroke
that's the high jump gun luke just had a
stroke made example
he just died
bring a [ __ ] mat in here and
put a [ __ ] stick up there like
five foot seven and i'll show you
[ __ ] how to do the high jump i
think when we do this again me and snoop
have to do a medley of some of the
events cause i think i'm five foot six i
can
high jump that's an easy play for me
tell you what we'll both be broadcasting
with neck
[Music]
in the braces
there's always tomorrow
sarah my wife just had to text me my
address where i lived
show you where my mind is no shirt no
shoes no metal no roger no rerun no rest
exactly remember that no roger no real
no right that was the thing no roger no
no rent they don't even know
we wouldn't know rick come on now y'all
don't know where that's from
don't
you're
worry
black person in this room right now you
don't say it with us you should be
ashamed of your damn self no rogers no
no rent no roger no no rent get it no
look we just made every white person
uncomfortable we apologize here at
peacock it's about comfort yeah not
discomfort can we show mike a clip of
little black aquaman and the water
please i'd like to see this clip too
we're going to see work too you said
something you got some dolphin in you
huh say something we got some dog in you
kids look at it look at it look at it
trying to analyze it oh yeah 100 yeah
yeah try to analyze it speaking of
efficient last thing you thought you
would see was a little black man
butterflying like that i'll kick his ass
what'd you say do you offend him
what are you talking about
i'm in the ocean man don't worry about
what i'm doing
look at that look at the stroke it's not
about what was on my feet it's about you
saying the technique is mike listen
definitely listen sure
look at that definitely spins on listen
listen listen
first of all it doesn't count because
you can't use fins in the race hey first
of all i don't know how
how good is his eyes to see that i have
fins on uh
[Laughter]
in women's beach volleyball the us duo
of april ross and alex
klein climate
climate alex kleinman came together for
dominant gold medal victory check it out
uh ari ar ariane i'm sorry [ __ ] what is
it guys
ariane
ariane thomas titmus ariane titmus okay
go back i got it uh now here's something
to get pumped up about venezuelan
weightlifter oh here's a doozy que domar
sanchez huh
god damn it almost uh 2021 bought the
end of the kardashians on e and the end
of kim and kanye in real life uh in the
divorce kim got the house and kanye got
the stadium that's right when they
separated kanye moved into atlanta's
mercedes-benz stadium this is actually
kanye's room let's take a look
[ __ ] really did more
yeah it looks like the women's gym at
the ncaa tournament look at this [ __ ]
remember they only had three weights
it looked like the olympic dressing room
and thank you
exactly
only kanye look at this [ __ ] man then he
went to a game
later that night
that was on top of the stadium that he
was sleeping up under yeah well when
they said kanye what you gotta do after
this i'm about to go downstairs a little
bit
[Laughter]
what
yeah i'm about to go right to sleep i
ain't gonna do too much after this
i ain't trying to be up all night i'm
gonna go right downstairs go to bed tell
them they gotta wrap this basketball
[ __ ] up
i got a big day tomorrow
but he was living there
kanye was spotted making an appearance
at one of those games we talking about
let's check it out
jesus christ
kyle got paint holes on his face
kanye walked in that [ __ ] looking like
a bank robber from the 80s
put the money in the bag [ __ ]
luther
you know they could always see who was
robbing them in a penny hole say you jab
ass [ __ ] put the money in the bag
[Laughter]
i don't want to hear [ __ ] you got to say
if it ain't the money in the bag hey man
i know you you don't know me stop
looking at me man
just put the money in the [ __ ] bag
go roll the clip again let me see what
he had on walking to the ship again
look at this [ __ ] here god
damn it oh god damn it kanye [ __ ] had
on the eddie murphy delirious outfit
with a stocking cap